bevor ich zu gleich zwei
wahlkampfveranstaltungen der cdu fahre
spreche ich erstmal mit den betroffenen
den menschen im stau in nrw wie
schlimmeres ekelhaft
wir glauben sie beim thema stau ist dass
selbst fahrende auto die lösung weil
dann könnten könnte das auto
eigenständig im stau stehen und sie
nehmen die bahn also werden wir überall
seinen staatsnamen spiel viel schneller
redet die verkehrslage zu laufen würde
würden sie nrw dann verlassen
nein würde ich das nicht sagen weil ich
mag weil es gar nicht geht wie würden
jan stau stehen
das ist auch leider wir fahren jetzt zur
cdu die partei die in nrw endlich alles
besser machen will obwohl das gutes an
die strafen nicht weil diese schon ganz
okay also man kann fahren
[Musik]
dann fordert bayern ruft immer hier
denen die gelder also einfach mal hier
hoch lückermann gerufen hier beruf
aufgeben veranstaltung ist ja heute wir
von der senioren-union gibt es denn
überhaupt eine andere union
es gibt wäre die frauen-union die junge
union die mittelstandsvereinigung und
dann geht sie meinen die frauen senioren
union die junge senioren union gibt
keine vereinigung der frauen union
die senioren und york die junge union
wie die senioren-union herum aus wie nrw
auch immer an die letzten tage der ddr
war wichtig die kanzlerin zu sehen
[Applaus]
um unser leben geht okay ich habe ein
bisschen angst bekommen und welche
chance es geht um unser leben
die ewigkeit warum auch warum auch genau
also können wir denn wer gar nichts
positives an entlastet würden
er hat charisma wie ein stück aus
[Applaus]
annahme nicht gelaufen
der lasse naja com will
belastet haben sie kurz zeit für ein
kurzes statement erlass des nrw geht
schlecht die bildung ist im eimer
wirtschaft im eimer was muss noch alles
passieren bis die cdu endlich den
richtigen kandidaten aufstellt das
müssen sie auch nicht vor mir
13 auf sich warten lassen
hier muss ich mich schnell eingelebt
aber die strafe doch so schlecht da
kriegen die reifen zu wenig profil armin
laschet oder rucksack nachprüfen
ein